my two favorite rappers are george
michael of wham and Tom Jones
they don't rap they don't rap how dare
you sir mr. Tom Jones Sir Tom Jones up
north with the snow grows colder I'm
Trever Longworth across the border I
looked up a girl that I once knew frozen
I thought that I was chosen to be the
father of the day to make myself scarce
while they come to be bargain for my
body and soul all the things ago routes
around me I won't go into the ozone I
want to cuddle up behind your backbone
I'll never stay long when I'm not wanted
I feel haunted that's a Tom Jones with
the Tom Joe sorry by the way I was doing
a show one time and Tom Jones was in the
audience and it was like well I got to
break out the rap yeah so I do the rap
and Tom Jones and that and that old
Hollywood way just look to me he goes no
you got that Sir Tom Jones it was the
greatest pretty sweet it was a good
night pretty sweet it was a good night
did you tell him what you thought about
the saxophone
I did not kept that to myself but I'm
glad you did that made the most sense
you can see Jimmy live at crackers
comedy club in Indianapolis Indiana
this Thursday through Saturday night
yeah yeah and you can download all 12
hours the 2018 part casteth on I was
quite funny on that Jim you were yeah if
I may die we didn't have time earlier I
will tell you now you were terrific I'm
gonna give it a solid 7 point 5 out of
10
that's high praise that's high praise I
don't think I should tell people how to
get this oh please now all 12 hours at
the 2018 part casteth on at never not
funny comm all the proceeds go to smile
train which as you know is a wonderful
charity you're a good man Gingka method
[Applause]
you